foreign
Nord I'm a scientist I work at fermilab
and University of Chicago typically but
for this year I'll be at MIT uh trying
to expand
my scope of thinking
when it comes to the intersection of
artificial intelligence education and
social advocacy
I am really impressed with the capacity
of computational algorithms like
artificial intelligence to do some
things
but I'm also really terrified by how
we're using them in society
I think it's the responsibility of
scientists who are helping to develop
these algorithms
to do more when it comes to helping the
public understand how they work and
advocating for the just use of these
algorithms
being a scientist for me Isn't just
about trying to understand the universe
is
also about making research spaces
healthy and hospitable so that people
have access to them
the pursuit of knowledge and the
development of this skill of doing
research and critical thinking it
shouldn't be a privilege
it should be there for for lots of
people for everyone to to enjoy and to
learn about the universe and to learn
about themselves and too many people are
systematically denied this
[Music]